Officials in Afghanistan say 12 army recruits were killed...
...in a suicide bomb attack in the eastern city of Jalalabad Monday afternoon.
A shaky UN-backed truce takes hold in Yemen after more than a year of fighting.
In India, police have detained five people for questioning...
...in connection with the temple fire in the state of Kerala...
...that killed about 100 people and injured 380.
Tensions in Greece remain high on the Idomeni border crossing...
...a day after Macedonian police used force to stop hundreds of migrants...
...as they tried to break through a border fence.
And finally, security is tight in Russia's southern Stavropol region...
...after three men, including at least one suicide bomber, attacked a rural police station.